[Music]
almost everything we use depends on
silicon semiconductors called chips
from your iphones your fridge your air
filter
the most advanced super computers the
most basic
toaster ovens what's turning on your
indicators what's turning on your radio
and your car
that's a chip today
about a trillion chips are made a year
or 128
for every person on the planet and
china's government is lending the
industry
the same strategic importance it gave to
its atomic bomb program
it's arguably a lot more important
because you are talking about
china becoming self-reliant on
the technology that powers all of
mankind's future scientific advances
the key semiconductor is the advanced
logic
chip it's the most expensive and complex
piece of silicon
that gives computers and smartphones
their intelligence
this is the microprocessors designed by
apple designed by qualcomm
are made by only a very few companies
and they're made on the very very most
advanced manufacturing right now
there's one company that's crucial when
it comes to making advanced
logic chips taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company
or tsmc
and it is a company that makes
customized chips
for a lot of global tech companies
including
apple and nvidia and mediatek
so when tsmc has a shortage entire
industries
shut down and this dependency on taiwan
worries western countries the other
concern that has been a voice by
others is the fact that china claims
taiwan
which is a democratically self-governing
island
china has always said it wants to take
over taiwan by force if necessary
but china's also worried since they too
rely on taiwan
which has strong ties to the u.s for
their chip
imports the result of all this
multi-billion dollar plans by multiple
countries
in a race to dominate the mother of all
cutting-edge technologies
[Music]
the transistors which give chips their
functionality are small
very small the way to measure
size in the chip industry is in
nanometers these are billionths
of a meter the current state of the art
is five nanometers they are smaller than
a virus
very soon we're going to get to the
point where these layers of materials
that we use to build up
a transistor on a chip are going to be
an
atom thick once we get to that point we
can't make them any smaller
the smaller transistors are the more you
can fit into a
chip which in turn will offer more
computing power
but making these chips has gotten so
incredibly complicated and
expensive but it's difficult to keep up
that's why the number of manufacturers
at the industry's cutting edge
has fallen from over 25 in 2000
to just three there are fewer and fewer
companies actually producing
leading edge silicon for a very simple
reason you need
15 20 billion dollars to build just one
semiconductor factory and that factory
is obsolete within five years
that means you need to be running that
plant 24 7.
it needs to be producing hundreds of
millions of devices
a year and those devices need to be
selling at a very high premium
otherwise you're losing money and there
are really only a few companies that
understand the brutal you know economics
of the industry and that they can play
that game and win
but now the american champion intel has
shown signs of a slowdown
although it's dominated the industry for
the last 30 years
it's starting to fall behind in
manufacturing and has announced that
like everyone else it may start
outsourcing some of its work
to tsmc what's really
changed though over the last decade is
that you've had what's called the birth
and the growth of foundries
these are companies that specialize only
in manufacturing
and take designs from other companies
and make them with the best process
technology
in the past they couldn't really keep up
with intel but now
particularly tsmc and until a secondary
extent samsung
have actually got ahead the net result
of that is that a company like qualcomm
a company like apple can design a
processor
send that design around the world
electronically and have that
design made into a piece of silicon on a
more advanced process
by volume south korea's samsung actually
makes more chips than any other
manufacturer
but the company mainly focuses on memory
chips rather than the custom made logic
chips that companies depend on tsmc
for everybody wants tsmc
to do their best stuff because tsmt are
better at it as
simple as that the economics and the
technology
they've won above 30 of the most
advanced
logic is done in those factories in
shinto
by tsmc engineers
both samsung and intel have recently
announced multi-billion dollar
investments in the foundry business
although they won't be a threat to tsmc
for years to come
but whether it's south korea the united
states or taiwan
china's relationship with all three is
less than ideal
not to mention a lot of the equipment
and software provided to tsmc
and samsung to manufacture chips is made
by u.s
companies there are only a select few
companies that can make these machines
that
scrape off these fine patterns with
ultra uv lasers you know this is
science fiction level technology applied
materials
here in california kla 10 core
lots of these companies that you've
never heard of are absolutely crucial in
the supply chain
in making these machines that then
translate into these multi-billion
dollar factories
that make chips and
the us has leveraged its position to
enact
sanctions on china banning the country
from using u.s
technology out of security concerns
so we're all familiar with the example
of huawei
whose smartphone business has basically
been
essentially obliterated by u.s sanctions
whether it's software whether it's
actual
chip components materials that go into
chips or equipment that you use to
fabricate chips
all of that is technically banned
the american tech embargo began as an
effort against huawei
over national security but bans and
restrictions
now affect at least 60 firms
these include smick china's chip
champion which has been put on a
blacklist
at the end of 2020 tsmc's sales to
chinese clients
dropped by roughly 70 and
for the first time ever huawei reported
a drop in revenue
i think china's rise as a superpower in
technology
is regarded as a threat to very
fundamental american interests
they are military foes and the last
thing washington wants is also to see
a technological foe with the wherewithal
or the capabilities to wage
technological warfare
on the united states
but u.s sanctions might not be such a
simple solution
china is the largest purchaser of chips
in the world as well as a manufacturer
of less
sophisticated chips for companies like
qualcomm and other american companies
bear in mind that a lot of american
businesses rely on china for growth
so there is very strong pushback from
the private sector
to allow the flow of american technology
to china to resume
but if you look at the overall picture i
think
the biden administration shares the
trump administration's objectives
in curtailing china's rise as a
technological power
and that's because that would have
ramifications for
really long term strategic goals
we're investing aggressively in areas
like semiconductors and batteries that's
what they're doing and others
so must we
but cutting china out completely isn't
an option
since much of the world depends on china
to manufacture most of their
electronics like iphones a chip designed
say by apple
in cupertino in california will be made
in taiwan then packaged into something
that's going to end up in an iphone
in the philippines that chip then makes
its way
to china where it gets plugged into an
iphone
that iphone then gets on a plane and
gets sold in europe
or maybe even comes back to cupertino
and gets sold
in the apple store so the semiconductor
supply chain is arguably one of the most
complex
and widely geographically spread supply
chains
in the world
from beijing's perspective u.s sanctions
are a way to keep china
at the bottom end of the supply chain
forever stuck
as a low-tier manufacturing hub
that's why china is determined to become
self-sufficient
and is shifting into its highest gear
during its annual
npc meeting in 2021 president xi jinping
pledged
1.4 trillion dollars to accelerate their
tech industry
and become totally independent from
foreign technology
one of the announcements that we've seen
come out since the npc
has been uh smick china's top chipmaker
signing an agreement to build a two and
a half billion dollar
semiconductor foundry or manufacturing
plant with shenzhen's government
and i think you'll see more of those
private public partnerships
where a private giant or entity such as
smick
drives more efficient private capital
into
national objectives smick
or semiconductor manufacturing
international corporation
is china's largest foundry although it's
still
decades behind taiwan's tsmc
china has shown its ability to throw
money and human resources at the
development
of mega projects but the chip industry
isn't quite the same thing there have
been
numerous failures um in terms of china's
domestic chip development effort
smig is an example of a success
but there have been plenty more that
have fallen by the wayside
literally hundreds of much smaller
corporations that
you and i have never heard of that
raised capital but
ultimately failed to deliver on its
goals
tsmc has shown it takes much more than
capital
and human resources it takes time
so tsmc was funded in 1987
and it has spent more than 30 years in
developing and creating its own
manufacturing technology it is just
not very likely that you cannot create
a comprehensive semiconductor ecosystem
overnight
and unlike the us or china taiwan's
economy is largely built around
semiconductors tsmc is located
in the small town of shinchu which hosts
a whole
ecosystem of other well-established chip
manufacturing
and packaging companies and the industry
also attracts
taiwan's best talent one of taiwan's
best paying
industry is the semiconductor industry
so with that
incentive a lot of school children would
see
the electrical engineering or anything
less related to the semiconductor
manufacturing as their top choice when
they
decide on which university departments
they want to go to
so in the u.s you have students choosing
to study computer science
or other subjects that would be more
related
to the skills that big tech companies
like google or
amazon require
likewise in china students are much more
likely to be attracted by companies like
tencent
baidu and alibaba or make their own app
one of the things that chinese officials
in recent years have been stressing
it's fine to build the world's best food
delivery app
but at the same time you need also to be
able to attract
talent into areas such as ai
quantum computing basic scientific
developments what we call the hard
sciences
or heart tech to counter the lack of
talent in the field china's been
recruiting talent from abroad
which has been controversial in taiwan
and the us
considering china's history of taking
intellectual property
china has been hiring aggressively from
taiwan over the past few years
and what the u.s may be concerned is
these people
may bring their know-how to china and
help china
build up a semiconductor industry more
swiftly and more effectively
and there is actually a well-known ip
theft
case the us memory maker micron has
sued taiwan's umc and a number of
engineers
micron alleged that some of these
engineers
formally had some know-how from micron
to help
umc's chinese partner to build up their
memory chips in china
but all these resources and talent still
don't necessarily equal success
to make a profit companies like tsmc
have a huge amount of orders
from a diverse number of clients and
that also takes years to build up
so if taiwan was suddenly cut off by a
china invasion for example there is no
tsmc replacement
let's say if apple decides to find
another partner
it will take years for them to
get this other chip maker to be ready
if at all so without tsmc
you will not be able to have chips in
your iphones
and you will not have chips for your
f-35
fighter jets that the u.s flies so it
will be
a very different world we are talking
about
without tsmc in it
this choke point came to light during
the pandemic
when a chip shortage cost the auto
industry billions of dollars
[Music]
the pandemic has been a fascinating
story and arguably a
a turning point moment for the
semiconductor industry
dial the clock back a year ago to early
2020
and the forecasts were dire economic
activity around the world in the
pandemic was
was going to come crashing down and that
was going to kill demand for
semiconductors
what really happened though was as we
were locked in in our homes
studying and working from home we felt
an increasing need
for the electronic services for the
electronic devices that had been around
us all the time but we felt a
much more intense need for them and that
had a knock-on huge effect in creating
demand
for semiconductors roll the clock
forward to where we are now
demand has come surging back and it's
come surging back in sectors where it
really wasn't expected to
for example the automotive industry
which thought that
essentially the world was ending that
there was no no demand for cars and they
were going to have to shut plants down
they're having to shut plants down
because they can't get enough chips
this prompted the us to sign deals with
tsmc
and samsung to build factories on their
own turf
if we see what's being built as a
an electronic cold war fully
materialized
that china goes its own way in
technology that europe and the us go in
another direction
then perhaps it makes increasingly more
economic sense to have facilities here
the biggest economic choke point of the
20th century
may have been oil passing through the
strait of hormuz
but now it's microscopic silicon
transistors
manufactured in taiwan but while the us
and china
are fighting for control of the
technology they still depend on each
other for the most part
the trade war really is a case of be
careful what you wish for
the chip industry brought attention to
itself and lobbied for action against
china for years
on ip protection now that it's happened
they're not happy with the situation why
they're not happy with that situation
because they depend upon
the chinese market it's the fastest
growing biggest market
they need to be able to sell chips into
china right now
china needs them china needs what
they're producing
massive wake-up call for china massive
call
to them to show that they need to be
independent
the worst case scenario for the us is
that china makes that leap
that this next five-year plan or the
five-year plan after that
finally hits home chinese chip
manufacturers emerge and become
competitive to intel to nvidia
to broadcom to what apple can produce
inside
the worst case scenario at least from a
globalist's point of view
is bipolarization of the world where you
have
u.s and china and countries around the
world
lining up behind one or the other it's
not good for
a lot of things just starting simply
with global trade
but if i may be allowed to wax lyrical
for a second
it ain't good for the advancement of
humankind
you